[Music]
so matt you write that china is using
climate change as a bargaining chip for
appeasing behavior from the west why do
you think that
well i think
china has made it fairly explicit in
recent days and weeks particularly a
comment from the foreign minister where
he said that climate change cannot be
separated from the larger people's
republic of china u.s relations
environment um and
this has become clear in in other
statements too there's a very aggressive
editorial in uh one of the communist
party newspapers about how
um actually they quite like britain at
the moment but america really has to
moderate its behavior if it wants a
climate
agreement if it wants cooperation on the
climate issue and it just looks to me as
if increasingly china thinks about this
issue in terms of what it can extract in
the way of
better behavior towards china
than
the issue itself
israel would you agree with that
um well not really i mean the global
times is notorious for aggressive
statements about almost everyone and you
know next week it might be you know the
the uk is is horrible and and the united
states is is our our close friend
this changes um depending on the agenda
of the global times um or its editor who
xi jin
as for wangy the foreign minister well
fortunately wangi doesn't do climate
negotiations for china and in fact the
foreign minister in china is not very
high up the pecking order so again the
foreign ministry is intent on displaying
warforia diplomacy and and being very
assertive in its
statements about foreign policy but the
real action is going on elsewhere so the
action is going on uh partly through the
working out of the 14-5 year plan partly
through the state council and largely
through xi jinhua who is the chief
climate negotiator who talks directly
with john kerry and they've met
nearly 20 times already so there clearly
is a lot of action going on uh which is
shielded the only talk about climate uh
in that negotiation and that's the one
that counts
well israel what do you think china
thinks about tackling climate change
because we hear so much about china you
know obviously it's the biggest polluter
in the world uh we hear a lot about its
coal use um does china care about
tackling climate change when we can't
even get many other countries around the
world even britain to care about
attacking climate change all that much
well um
it depends you know who cares and what
do you think they care about um
certainly climate change has been very
high up the political agenda in china
since china became the world's biggest
emitter which was in 2005 and since then
a policy on climate change has been
elaborated which has partly been about a
domestic transition which we would all
love to see go faster and there's a lot
of frustration around that
but it's also about industrial
strategies so china identified very
early on
that
the technologies of the future would
likely be low-carbon technologies and
built an industrial strategy around
having a strong position in those and
that gave china a direct interest in a
carbon-constrained world because it
hopes to supply the market and does
supply the market for a
carbon-constrained world and that also
fed into china's own mitigation
strategies which as i say
really need to go faster but
nevertheless china has the largest by
far installed capacity of renewables and
one of china's problems
was that it had gone so far down the the
its root of dependence on coal that it
takes a lot to turn that tank around but
if you look at all the indicators that
china has been
measuring its behavior against for the
past decade things like energy density
how much energy you you consume to
produce a a dollar of gdp and so on and
indeed co-use and co-dependency and
primary energy all of those are moving
in the right direction they're just not
going fast enough
matt what do you make of this idea of we
have we've got of china being polluted
but at the same time it's moving into
the renewables industry in terms of
technology could renewable technology be
you know the next telecoms where china
has you know stolen a march and we
hadn't quite even realized it's market
leadership and maybe in the future the
west will rely on west on chinese
renewable tech because we've got this
idea of china being a polluting
power rather than a green power
well china certainly supplies an
enormous
proportion of the world's renewable
technologies
particularly with respect to some of the
ingredients of those technologies the
rare earths and other minerals that need
to go into
the batteries and
magnets in wind turbines the solar
panels and so on china sees sees it as
an enormous opportunity and if if we are
rushing headlong into trying to become
reliable
reliant on unreliable renewables
in the west as we are then that is a
fantastic opportunity for china to sell
us stuff and sadly most of what we're
installing in the way of wind and solar
in the west is indeed supplied by china
and at the same time the reason china is
able to do that is because actually you
need a lot of coal to make this stuff
you need coal to fuel uh to make wind
turbines for example and and you need a
lot of oil to fuel the vehicles that do
the the mining and so on and you know
the quantity of coal that china is
consuming is truly gigantic it's about a
thousand gigawatts of coal-fired
capacity
at the moment and adding another 100 in
the pipeline well
britain has less than 100
total
generating capacity of all kinds
although china is much much many more
times bigger than the uk with a much
larger population as well indeed and
it's getting worse uh they're uh they're
um
uh
but i mean per capita would it be less
gigawatts per person probably they're
using coal to make oil at the moment
which is a extremely uh carbon intensive
process uh and uh they're not even going
to peak their coal use that sorry their
emissions
until 2030 um and not gonna head for uh
net zero until uh after 2060. so
they're pretty empty promises coming out
of china on the environmental thing and
yet they get a very easy ride from
western environmentalists you never hear
them criticizing the chinese regime
they're very critical of western
governments and i don't fully understand
why that is
well as well
well i'm not sure who matt talks to but
i talk to a lot of environmentalists and
i hear criticisms all the time and and
if you
you know if you go online and look
what's being said about by uh western
environmentalists about for example
china's co-use um it's it there is no
there is no praise at all for for china
there's praise for china where china
deserves praise as there would be for
any other country i mean it one of the
one of the the difficulties about
talking rationally about china is is the
fact that china is so big and as as we
all know there are many ways to measure
emissions or historic emissions per
capita emissions and so on and in per
capita terms china is about seven tons
per head per year now um
if the united states is at 18. so you
know again if you're looking at
at the the degree of effort
um
you can make a case for china um but i
don't think that this particular finger
pointing is very helpful we all need to
do uh more on climate change certainly
britain has the leakiest and most
inefficient housing stock in all of
europe and we still don't have a plan to
address that so
i think the best way to approach things
like
cop 26 is to look to our own
house and and put it in order and
encourage others to do the same and
china is certainly not the worst in this
respect it's the biggest
but in policy terms it's not the worst
well matt let me bring you in on this
one because i know from your writings
and your book that you believe in
economic growth and that you believe
with greater economic growth some of
these environmental problems can then be
tackled you know in using technology to
tackle climate change rather than you
know maybe obscene obstinacy or hair
shirts and that sort of stuff if china
is still behind america in terms of per
capita pollution isn't that because
china is still behind america in terms
of capital gdp i.e the chinese people
are still transitioning to a much more
middle class developed
living standards so should they be given
a slightly different understanding on
their pollution in the same way that for
example the west went through the
industrial revolution
well what happens when a country
industrializes is that at first it uses
more energy
and then gradually becomes more
efficient isabel made this point earlier
and we've seen
enormous improvements in the west in the
amount of emissions you need to produce
a dollar of gdp or a pound of gdp
and that's because of innovation it's
because of new technologies that enable
us to use fossil fuels more efficiently
to switch to lower carbon fossil fuels
like natural gas rather than
coal
and to use other technologies like
nuclear i'm not at all convinced that
renewables are in any way relevant to
that transition because
an awful lot of fossil fuels is used in
producing them they're very low energy
efficiency in terms of energy
return on energy invested they're
extremely unreliable so you have to have
backups to them if we want to solve this
problem if we want to have
a a functioning modern industrial
wealthy society
without producing any carbon emissions
then we're either going to have to
tackle
burying carbon in the ground through a
carbon capture and storage industry
or we're going to have to get very
serious about nuclear fission and fusion
in the longer term i personally think
it's the the the most of the rest uh is
simply a waste of time and playing into
the hands of those who uh who you know
really don't care about the environment
they just care about making money and
you know frankly filling the north sea
with with industrial structures um while
uh doing an enormous amount of very
dirty mining in china for the materials
doesn't feel to me like an
environmentally beneficial thing to be
doing well but do you think that china's
coal-fueled economic growth is something
that is you know
understandable
or rather justifiable
well
clearly coal is an extremely efficient
form uh source of energy
there's no question about that we i come
from the northeast of england uh where
coal mining is is you know built the the
prosperity of this country there's no
question about that um
but uh the
the
degree to which china is prepared to
expand that industry and use it in
pretty inefficient ways
doesn't seem to me something we should
simply ignore and excuse
i don't think anyone is ignoring or
excusing china's call use to be fair
there are questions around energy
security which are being exacerbated by
jewish strategic tensions which may
explain part of china's
continuing uh expansion of its domestic
coal
but you know china has promised to peak
its emissions and that will involve
closing down a great deal of its coal
capacity it's promised to peak its
emissions by 2030 or before actually and
certainly it's net zero target is 2016
not 2016 or after as as as matt said
there are other ways that countries
change their energy profile beyond
innovation
and
one of them is by changing their
industrial base and china has gone
through that
very heavily emitting you know
construction of infrastructure all that
heavy industrial development which uh
countries tend to go through in the in
the rapid sort of catch up phase and
then they transition to higher value
technologies they stop doing so much you
know heavy dirty stuff they they built
all their infrastructure so their
emissions tend to level off uh because
they're engaged in economic activities
that demand less primary energy input
the other thing that we did of course
was we outsourced our emissions in a
very large uh degree to to china by
outsourcing manufacturing to a low-wage
economy in china and and
almost all western countries did this
which impacted their own emissions
profile but of course did
make china's go the other way so there
are
this is an endless complicated argument
if you want to go the route of
you know
telling a simple story about emissions
it doesn't really work and as i said i
think the best way to tackle this
problem is for each country to
to try it's uh to try its best to put
its own house in order and china you
know for all the frustrations that we
all have uh with china's emissions and
particularly its coal sector
it's a great deal better than it was ten
years ago and as long as it goes on
moving in the right direction i think we
should encourage it to move faster
rather than criticize it for everything
it does matt would you like to come back
on that
well i i just don't think this
conversation is happening in a vacuum
the point is this is happening at a time
when there are huge human rights
problems in china a terrible suppression
of liberty appalling things happenings
to the uyghur peoples the crushing of
hong kong
and a terrible pandemic that originated
in china and the investigation into the
origin of which we are simply not being
given a transparent opportunity to
pursue
and it feels as if
quite a lot of politicians in the west
are pulling their punches on some of
those issues
because they want chinese cooperation on
climate and that seems to me it should
be brought to the attention of the
public i i i'm not sure that there's any
evidence for that often politicians pull
their punches on china i agree and i i
don't dissent from
anything that mata said about the human
rights abuses and so on um but they tend
to pull their punches for uh for
economic reasons because they hope to do
business and you know uh we we saw that
particularly with the cameron government
which um i think that was fairly closely
acquainted with um
which you know adopted a policy of
complete appeasement in a basement to
china and was lavishly praised amongst
others by the global times for doing so
and and essentially told yes that's how
we want foreigners to behave um i don't
think it did anybody very much good to
be honest
but what i find
most puzzling about this argument is i'm
not quite sure how not cooperating on
china improves human right and not
cooperating on climate improves human
rights in china or indeed improves any
of the other ills that we wish to
address
it it makes no difference
well i think it it's it it's more a
question of whether or not uh in our
pursuit of climate we are letting that
get a climate agreements we are letting
that get in the way of other interests
and and i think that does happen and i
think you know the the degree to which
uh the the conference of the parties in
glasgow
um has
uh
partly because it's been delayed for a
year um uh intruded on almost every uh
diplomatic conversation over the last
year or two
is problematic we know that the glasgow
conference is not going to achieve very
much we know that because it's the 26th
such meeting and the previous 25 haven't
solved the problem and they've come up
with some extraordinary slights of hands
to sort of pretend they're solving the
problem i mean the paris agreement
basically came up with a non
it insisted it was going to come up with
a binding treaty in fact it came up with
a binding treaty to have non-binding
promises which is a sort of slight of
hand
and the you know the cancun agreement
came up with a
an agreement to create but not to fund a
fund of climate
we're going to have some similar sort of
compromise out of glasgow is it really
worth it uh to have these tens of
thousands of people descend descending
upon britain to have this
rather meaningless conversation and at
the same time i do think we pull our
punches on china because of it
and yes i do think that we we need to be
calling much more openly
for example for proper investigation
into the origin of the virus when
australia did that they simply had trade
sections slapped on them that just
doesn't feel like a very sensible way
for a a global power to behave
well i i'm i'm very happy to criticize
china for for for that i just don't
think it's related to the question of
climate australia um wasn't complaining
about
china's climate policy and australia
actually is pretty much a laggard in
climate negotiations it's one of the
countries with a very very high per
capita emissions so i i'm not quite sure
the relevance of of of that episode to
cop 26 and the idea that the conferences
and the whole unf uh triple c process
hasn't achieved anything is frankly uh
extremely questionable i mean look at
the counterfactual where would we be
without it our emissions would be much
higher we would not be innovating we
would not be attempting an energy
transition without this whole process
it's a very long and complicated
business to upend uh the world's uh
energy sources and the great many people
of course have vested interests in the
existing uh energy sources and and the
traditional high emitting carbon sectors
and they obfuscate and they resist and
they cause a great deal of difficulty um
to those who are trying to find a way
through but that doesn't mean that no
progress is made i mean we have made
enormous progress both in our scientific
understanding of the human impacts on
climate and in the many ways that we can
tackle it and
many countries have reduced their carbon
footprint dramatically the european
union has a really remarkable uh uh
project the eur the the european green
deal
uh countries are coming up with
transition plans as a result of the
paris agreement none of that would have
happened without you
the the major reduction in uh the
emissions intensity in the united states
was due to the discovery of shale gas
and the cheap gas replacing coal as a
source of fuel that's the big impact
that's come on emissions in in there and
the per capita emissions of the united
states are still twice as high as china
so it's not really because you said that
the the emissions reduction had come as
a result of the treaties i don't think
that's the case the emissions reduction
has come as a result of changes in
technology within the fossil fuel
industry and other reductions have come
as a result of policies adopted uh
because of the unf triple c process and
the discussions around climate change
and the reiteration of the scientific
evidence of of anthropogenic climate
change all of this has been contested at
every point um but nevertheless it has
managed to advance and i find it
really quite surprising um
that you should argue that it would have
happened regardless given the degree of
resistance that there has been by uh you
know any number of sectors and and
interests that that wish not to see us
uh change
well let's let's continue talking about
climate change and tackling climate
change and cop26 closer to cop26 but
we're running out of time so matt i just
want to finish on one final question to
you which is that you mention all of
these human rights abuses
that are happening in china all of the
ways it's behaving in ways that the west
doesn't like
going forward what do you think is the
west's relationship with china on
climate change what do you think that
should be
if these other things don't change so
what i guess what i'm asking is is
cooperation justifiable should it happen
if china doesn't stop oppressing the
uyghur people if china doesn't stop
oppressing the hong kong people you know
if china doesn't stop doing these other
things
should we just not cooperate with china
on climate change
no i think of course we have to
cooperate and on climate change and on
everything else we you know we we live
in the same planet and we have to try
and find a way of of living with people
but i think that the process of these
vast meetings and the lead-up to them
and the the desire to extract
concessions has led us to
sometimes be somewhat uh inadequate in
the way we talk about other issues
and
i therefore think that it'd be much
better to get away from these vast
annual meetings with uh
i'm sorry to say futile outputs because
they are futile uh seen from outside by
ordinary people
these are talking shops that produce
pieces of paper these aren't where the
action happens and you know the the
improvements have come from technology
not from policy ninety percent of them i
would say
[Music]
you